- If you had to fire someone
from the Jets who would it be?
- Oh my god, if I had to fire somebody
from the New York Jets
it would be, ooh, this is really good.
Yeah!
You got your perspective.
(crowd cheers)
I just wanna be happy.
(upbeat music)
How are you, what's your name?
- I'm Chris, nice to meet you.
- Josh, nice to meet you.
- Josh, how are you?
Nice to meet you guys.
- I'm 17 years old, I'm
going off the NYU next year,
Tisch for TV and film.
- Awesome.
- So about three four years ago
I started a business
called EJB Entertainment.
So it's an event and
video production company.
I love the business,
I love the leadership,
and love the creativity so I
think it's the next step of
how can I take--
- I think that's a good observation.
So for me that's kind of weirdly
what I was hoping you would say.
If you're asking what's
the next step for me
I think you actually
view this next four years
as a context builder
and education, you know,
excursion and so for me my hot take is
how do you get closest to, you know,
and you've heard this
for me if you follow me,
how do you get closest
to who you wanna be?
Get as close to the son of
the thing that you wanna be
and you will win if you're capable.
Like if you want to be Jimmy Fallon,
if you want to be Steven Spielberg,
at all costs you need to work
for those people for free.
Like to me the if I think
back to what did I do
and there's always things to do better,
I think that I didn't have to
go back to Springfield, Jersey
and work at Wine Library all four years.
I think one of those
years working at Walmart's
corporate office in Bentonville
would've done me a lot of good.
So I think if you've made
the commitment to like,
hey I'm going to learn
certain things from NYU,
I would say with every
other minute you have
instead of building a business,
which you've already done
and have some understanding about,
I would try to get more context
from things that you wanna be, right.
Like I'm flabbergasted by
kids taking a job they hate
for $4,000 more so they can buy something
or have slightly, have two
roommates instead of three
versus when they wanna be something
having the access to that
from, you know, 17 to 25
to then go on and do it for
the rest of their lives.
So for me making people
laugh and producing movies,
it's fuckin' what comedian
can you work for for free
and get as, to me it's like,
if you have your four favorite comedians
and they all say yes,
whoever lets you be the
closest to real life.
'Cause the context of seeing it
is disproportionately valuable.
Jason, you you watched me from afar,
you did what DRock did for others,
what was the biggest thing you learned
in the first 30 days of being here
that wasn't obvious even though
you passionately watched us from afar?
- So to me what he
learned in like week one
is like disproportionately valuable.
Like eliminating subjectiveness
and valuing speed and output
is a 2019 model that matters
'cause the internet's
distribution is unlimited
whereas old television and
film you had to overthink it
'cause you put it out
once and that was that.
- It's volume.
The best the best thing
that can happen to you
is having an experience similar to that
within the craft that you care about.
♪ Never wanted you to change ♪
- My name is Alyi V and
I met you awhile ago.
I'm a radio personality
on Sirius XM Radio,
I'm also a celebrity event planner
and right now I'm living between
my dreams and my reality.
I have a nine to five job
and I recently, you know,
have made some money off of my career,
so my question is, when is
the right time for me to say
I gotta leave this job.
- Whenever you can afford to,
predicated on how you live your lifestyle.
Like I think a lot more people out there
can leave their jobs a lot earlier
if they're willing to live less fancy
and realize that happiness
is the ROI in life.
I mean, the amount of people
who are watching this right now
who I would just wish
would sell their home,
go rent, which would then
allow them to quit their job.
Or if they're renting,
stop buying dumb shit
which would allow them to leave their job.
The real answer is when
can I go to my dream
versus my reality is predicated
on how much you're spending
in your real life on shit you don't need.
Now, everyone's in different life cycles.
When I look at these youngsters,
especially if somebody's under 25,
I'm like live with 19
of your fucking friends
and eat fucking 99-cent
fuckin' White Castle and go.
Your stomach's still good,
like you can go, right.
Other people have kids and they're,
but to me the conversation
that nobody's having
is what's your expenses look like?
- Well I still live in the Bronx so.
- Respect, respect.
- I'm in a nice studio
apartment in the Bronx.
- But like the question
is, but you could--
- Live with mom.
- You could.
- I could.
- And not that I think you should,
the question though for a lot
of people is like, hey I'm,
especially people that have
a little something going.
You know, people that
are still in their head
and haven't even started
singing or selling rum
or doing events like that,
they probably have to wait a
little bit for some foundation
but like to me it's like
when do you jump in the pool?
Like, right, when you're a kid,
like it just happens, right?
You could, but then you would say to me,
but if we were having drinks
and we were best friends since
grammar school you'd be like,
yeah, but I to do that,
like, I'm dating, or this.
Like, there is no right answer
but the reason I'm giving you this answer
is nobody's talking about expenses.
Like I've had this
conversation with some friends
and after an hour over like a hot dog
you realize like, maybe you
don't have to do your nails
three times a week, maybe
you don't have to go
to two vacations, you can go to one,
like, it gets really interesting.
I think it comes down to
how much is your reality killing you
and how much is your dream pulling at you.
Some people, the deltas enormous,
they fucking hate their job
and they just love singing
more than breathing.
So for me I'm like, go rogue.
For other people, like,
yo, I don't mind my,
I don't love my job, but it's all right.
I think like three out of
five days a week I'm like,
cool, I like my coworkers, like,
and my dream is like I
really, really like it,
that becomes the question, right.
The reason I was a D and F student
was I couldn't breathe if
I wasn't an entrepreneur
long before it was something cool.
And that's who I became.
The same way that athletes
just, they suck at school,
they suck at everything else,
like the ones that make it to the league,
they stay out of trouble,
they suck at school,
they make it to the league
'cause they were just,
they couldn't breathe if
they weren't playing ball,
- Okay.
- Do you understand?
And that's the delta,
that's the actual practical
answer to your question.
- What's going on, Alyi V with GaryVee
for the quickest interview I've ever done.
What is the shittiest
wine you've ever tasted?
- Berenger White Zinfandel.
- Okay, if you had to fire someone
from the Jets who would it be?
- Oh my god, if I had to fire
somebody from New York Jets
it would be, ooh, this is really good,
the parking attendants.
- Okay, what Kardashian
sister has the best branding?
- Kendall.
- Kendall, oh that's interesting, okay.
- I'm a marathon runner
and I think Kendall
is playing the longest game of the bunch.
- Okay, and my last question,
rapper Soulja Boy said
he had the best comeback
of 2018, better than Tyga.
In your opinion who had
the best comeback of 2018?
- Kodak.
- Really?
- mm-hmm.
- Can you see why quickly?
- 'Cause his album is just next-level.
(calm music)